well the reason why I say Oh healthcare
is that for stimulus you want be able to
look you want to look to somewhere you
could spend a lot of money quickly and
healthcare has the advantage of it's a
huge huge sector it's a 2.4 trillion
it's about seventeen percent of the
economy so you could reasonably look to
expand that and you can look to expand a
relatively quickly and the way I propose
doing that was an employer tax credit
where we have you know somewhere around
30 40 million workers that don't get
employer-provided health insurance so if
we give employers a tax credit let's say
three thousand a worker to give those
workers health care coverage then my
guess is a awful lot of them would do
that and what that would fairly quickly
do is on the one hand it would employ
people in the insurance industry not
something I'm anxious to do but as a
stopgap that's a good thing to do it
would give people health care employing
them in the health care sector and to
some extent of course these people if
they don't have insurance they're paying
it out of pocket so what that would mean
is they will pay much less out of pocket
they'll have more money to spend and
these tend to be more moderate income
people so they are likely to spend it so
I thought that could give a good boost
to the economy now to actually transform
healthcare we have to go further I want
to see is have a public plan that people
could buy into but the idea would be
let's take advantage of the fact that we
actually just need to create demand so
in certain sense we don't mind the waste
waste waste right now is fine but what
we could do is one give people coverage
to Edward go and then say 2011-2012
presumably we'd have a national health
care plan ramped up that people could
buy into if they chose and then we'd
have a mechanism in place that could
start to control costs so I think that
would be a very good way to look to do
something short-term boost the economy
and really jump-started stretch national
health care insurance which has to be
top priority and anyone's to my mind on
anyone's agenda right now
the other sort of two my my good way to
do stimulus is big stimulus i should say
is what i've called a payer play tax
credit pay for play i should say which
would give employers a tax credit for
providing workers of paid time off so
the way it would work is we pick a sum
of money let's say twenty five hundred
dollars per worker and we tell employers
that will pay them will pay them to
offset any amount to paid time off that
they give their workers up to twenty
five hundred dollars a year and the paid
time off could take the form of paid
sick days paid parental leave paid
vacations shortening the standard work
week and what that would do is on the
one hand it would directly get money and
into workers pockets but more
importantly at least it might be more
importantly that we're giving a benefit
that people are likely to value we're
way behind the rest of the world by the
way in this front everywhere else if you
look to Germany Britain any country you
pick they all have paid sick leave paid
vacation paid parental leave we're
really the outlier that way so it jumps
start us that way but in terms of the
economy the stimulus to the economy
let's say we got employers 100 million
workers to take advantage of this and
they shorten the work time of their
workers an average of five percent well
they're seeing just as much demand as
they did previously because the workers
have just as much money in their pocket
as they did previously but they get five
percent fewer hours in principle what
they're going to want to do is hire five
percent more workers that translates
into five million jobs so the nice part
of this story instead of five million
people being unemployed we have we have
105 million people now employed and
they're all working so much shorter
hours in taking taking it this instead
of unemployment is leisure time as paid
vacations paid parentally of whatever it
might be so I think that's a very good
way to deal with sort of this basic
problem we don't have enough demand in
the economy at the moment one we do want
to increase demand but to why not just
let everyone work shorter hours
you